TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
SET TONIGHT.
HE WAS AT CAMP DAVID OVER THE
WEEKEND AS THE PRESIDENT AND
SEVERAL TOP CONGRESSIONAL
REPUBLICANS HASHED OUT THEIR
PRIORITIES ON IMMIGRATION AND
WELFARE REFORM.
MILLER THEN APPEARED ON CNN
YESTERDAY TO DISCUSS ALL OF
MICHAEL WOLFF'S NEW BOOK.
CNN PULLED THE PLUG ON THE
INTERVIEW.
>> THE REASON WHY I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S EXPERIENCE
IS WHAT I'VE SEEN WITH HIM
TRAVELING TO MEET THOUSANDS OF
FOREIGN LEADERS WITH HIS
INCREDIBLE WORK.
>> YOU ARE NOT ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
>> YOU HAVE 24 HOURS A DAY OF
INTIME TRUMP MATERIAL.
YOU WILL NOT GIVE 3 MINUTES --
>> I GET IT.
THERE'S ONE VIEWER THAT YOU CARE
ABOUT RIGHT NOW AND YOU'RE BEING
OBSEQUIOUS, BEING A FACTOTUM IN
ORDER TO PLEASE HIM.
I THINK I'VE WASTED ENOUGH OF MY
VIEWERS TIME.
THANK YOU.
AS REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS CALL FOR
JEFF SESSIONS TO RESIGN --
>> Tucker: THAT GOT PRETTY
INTENSE AND IT CONTINUED DURING
CNN LEAKED A TRANSCRIPT OF
MILLER'S POST-INTERVIEW REMARKS.
IF THEY WERE APPARENTLY ON TAPE,
ALL DONE IN AN EFFORT TO
EMBARRASS HIM.
STEPHEN MILLER JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS A LOT FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: CNN CALLED AROUND
TO NEWS ORGANIZATIONS AND SAID
YOU WERE EXTORTED OFF THE SET BY
SECURITY.
PRESUMABLY YOU ARE NOT A
PHYSICAL FIGHT, YOU ARE NOT
ARMED.
DO YOU THINK IF YOU HAVE BEEN, I
DON'T KNOW, A MEMBER OF MS-13
HERE ILLEGALLY, THAT CNN WOULD
HAVE HAD SECURITY PULL YOU OFF
THE SET?
>> I WOULD ASSUME IF I WERE A
MEMBER THEY WOULD BE CLAMORING
TO GET ME INTO THE VOTING BOOTH.
I THINK THAT LIKE MANY THINGS
CNN SAYS, THE STORY HAS THE MOST
IMPORTANT VIRTUE OF ALL CNN
STORIES AS BEING NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW
IS TRUE, WHAT IS STRIKING TO ME
ABOUT THE WHOLE THING.
THERE WAS A VIDEO APPARENTLY
TAKEN WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF
YOU ON THE SET AFTER THE SEGMENT
ENDED DURING THE COMMERCIAL
BREAK, AND SOMEONE APPARENTLY
FROM CNN, I DON'T KNOW WHO ELSE
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO IT, LEAKED
THAT TO OTHER NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> IT'S JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
CNN'S VERY LOW JOURNALISTIC
STANDARDS.
I WAS GLAD TO HAVE PEOPLE HERE
WHAT I SET ON CAMERA AND OFF
CAMERA.
CNN HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
GIVING THEIR VIEWERS HONEST
INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: SO HE WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
THE DACA DEBATE IS OBVIOUSLY THE
FOCUS OF A LOT OF ENERGY IN THE
CONGRESS RIGHT NOW.
THE PRIORITIES FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION YOU HAVE SAID OUR
ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION,
FINANCING A BORDER WALL AND
ENDING THE DIVERSITY LOTTERY.
OF THOSE THREE, WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
PRIORITY FROM YOUR POINT OF
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS THAT
ANYTHING YOU DO ON DACA IT WILL
HAVE PREDICTABLE CONSEQUENCES.
YOU WILL HAVE AN INCREASE IN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION SO YOU WILL
NEED TO HAVE A WALL.
COUNTRY AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH
CHAIN MIGRATION.
IF THE DEAL WITH THE VISA
LOTTERY.
AMERICA.
DONALD TRUMP HAS A VERY RADICAL
IDEA AND THAT IS WHEN WE MAKE
CHANGES TO THE IMMIGRATION LAWS,
THE GROUP WE SHOULD BE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT HIS EVERYDAY
HARDWORKING AMERICANS, THE
WHO PAY THEIR TAXES, SHOW UP AND
VOTE.
THE PEOPLE WERE LOYAL TO THIS
COUNTRY AND DONALD TRUMP IS
SAYING OUR COUNTRY SHOULD BE
LOYAL TO THEM IN RETURN.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS ARGUE
BACK THAT ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION
AND ENDING THE DIVERSITY LOTTERY
WOULD PREVENT A LOT OF PEOPLE --
DECENT PEOPLE FROM COMING INTO
THE COUNTRY.
WHAT IS THEIR ARGUMENT AGAINST
FINANCING THE BORDER WALL?
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY OPPOSE
THAT?
>> AS YOU KNOW, THEY ALL VOTED
FOR A BORDER BARRIER, A HARD
PHYSICAL BORDER BARRIER BACK IN
2006.
HILLARY CLINTON VOTED FOR,
ET CETERA.
A NEW POSITION THEY APPARENTLY
HAVE THAT THEY ARE OPPOSED TO
ANY FORM --
POINT FOR DEMOCRATS?
A BUNCH OF THEM HAVE SAID,
INCLUDING IN LEADERSHIP, WE ARE
WALL, WHY?
>> IF DEMOCRATS OPPOSE A BORDER
WHILE THEY ARE JUST SAYING THEY
WORLD.
MOST OF THEM ARE GOOD,
HARDWORKING, DECENT, HONEST,
PRINCIPLED PEOPLE.
TO BRING PEOPLE AND BASED ON
THEIR ABILITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE ECONOMY, TO STAY PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS AND TO UPLIFT THE
NATION AS A WHOLE.
YOU THINK ABOUT OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM OF CHAIN MIGRATION.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE
ADMITTED ABOUT 10 MILLION PEOPLE
THROUGH OUR CHAIN MIGRATION
SYSTEM.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW MANY PEOPLE
THAT IS, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
EVERY HOUR THAT'S ABOUT THE SIZE
OF A HIGH SCHOOL AUDITORIUM.
EVERY DAY IT'S THE SIZE OF A
LARGE HIGH SCHOOL.
EVERY WEEK A SMALL CITY.
EVERY MONTH THE MEDIUM TO
AVERAGE SIZE CITY.
EVERY YEAR A VERY LARGE CITY, A
CITY THE SIZE OF
WASHINGTON, D.C., OR
SAN FRANCISCO.
EVERY SINGLE YOU'RE JUST THERE
CHAIN MIGRATION.
WHAT IS THE EFFECTIVE OUT ON
TAXPAYERS?
WHAT IS THE UPPER LEFT EFFECT OF
THAT ON WAGE EARNERS?
>> Tucker: AND THAT'S ILLEGAL.
>> THAT'S JUST FOLKS COMING IN
ON GREEN CARDS THROUGH CHAIN
MIGRATION.
>> Tucker: I ALWAYS ASK THIS
QUESTION OF PROPONENTS OF
IMMIGRATION, INCLUDING OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
COUNTRIES, MOVING HER EVERY
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
>> I HAVE MY OWN VIEWS ON IT,
BUT I THINK THE IMPORTANT POINT
IS ENDING CHAIN MIGRATION THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS CALLED FOR IS
NECESSARY NOT JUST FOR ECONOMIC
SECURITY BUT FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
IF YOU RECENT ATTEMPTED TERRORIT
ATTACK IN NEW YORK.
BROUGHT TO THE CHAIN MIGRATION
SYSTEM.
THEY CAME THROUGH HER NEPHEW'S
GREEN CARD.
IF THAT'S JUST NOT A SMART WAY
FOR A COUNTRY TO RUN ITS
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
>> Tucker: WHAT SHOULD BE THE
CRITERIA FOR ENTRY?
PROFICIENCY IN THE LANGUAGE?
WHAT ECONOMIC SKILLS DO YOU
HAVE?
DO HAVE A BACKGROUND IN
SCIENCES?
YOU HAVE A BACKGROUND IN LAW OR
WRITING?
LOOKED AT THINGS LIKE YOUR AGE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU BRING IN
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSE ON SOCIETY,
SO YOU WANT FOLKS PRIMARILY IN
THEIR WORKING YEARS.
>> Tucker: WE INTERVIEWED
SOMEONE LAST WEEK AND SAID WHO
WILL PICK THE STRAWBERRIES?
HOW MANY IMMIGRANTS, LOW-WAGE,
LOW SKILLED IMMIGRANTS DO WE
NEED A YEAR FOR THE AGRICULTURE
SECTOR?
>> AS YOU KNOW, ONLY ABOUT 1% OF
THE IMMIGRANT POPULATION OF THE
COUNTRY WORKS IN AGRICULTURE.
IT'S DISCUSSED A LOT BUT IT'S A
VERY SMALL PORTION OF THE
OVERALL LABOR FORCE.
THE TYPICAL JOBS AT A LOWER
SKILLED IMMIGRATION NOMADIC
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS YOU MIGHT BE
CONSTRUCTION WORK, IT MIGHT BE
HOSPITALITY WORK, RESTAURANT
WORK, IT MIGHT BE NOT WORKING AT
ALL AND JUST GOING ONTO THE
WELFARE SYSTEM IF THERE ISN'T A
JOB FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
>> Tucker: IF THERE'S NO CLEAR
ECONOMIC RATIONALE FOR AN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE THERE IS ONE,
LOW SKILLED IMMIGRANTS, THEN WHY
DOES THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SYSTEM SO VEHEMENTLY?
WHAT MOTIVATES THEM?
>> YOU ARE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTION BUT I THINK THE CONTEXT
OF THIS DEBATE, THE QUESTION
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING
FORTH FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS WHEN WE HAVE AN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, WHOSE NEEDS
THE NEEDS OF SPECIAL INTERESTS?
FOREIGN NATIONALS AND THE NEEDS
OF OUR OWN COUNTRY AND OUR OWN
WORKERS?
AT THE END OF THE DAY OUR HOPE
FOR A BIPARTISAN DEAL WAS YOU
HAVE ENOUGH DEMOCRATS SAY THAT
LISTENING TO THE VOTERS IN THE
VOICE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SAYING WE WANT TO SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE FOR
THE SO EXCEPTIONAL AS FOR THE
FIRST TIME THAT I CAN REMEMBER
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THIS
COUNTRY WHO WHEN HE TALKS BUT
IMMIGRATION, HE TALKS ABOUT WHAT
IS RIGHT FOR THE EVERYDAY
HARDWORKING PERSON.
>> Tucker: WE ARE ALMOST OUT
OF TIME SO I JUST WANT TO GET TO
ONE QUICK POLITICAL QUESTION,
ANY DEAL WITH THESE THREE
COMPONENTS IN IT.
IT BORDER WALL, REDUCING CHAIN
MIGRATION, ENDING DIVERSITY
LOTTERY.
IT WHERE IS THE WIGGLE ROOM ON
MAKE A CHOICE.
THEY CARE A LOT ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
WE ARE SEEING IF YOU WANT TO
MAKE A DEAL THEN YOU HAVE TO
TOO.
IF THEY ARE A ABLE TO AGREE ON
THOSE TERMS THAT WE CAN HAVE A
DEAL.
AN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT TEN,
20, 30 YEARS FROM NOW PRODUCES
MORE ASSIMILATION, HIGHER WAGES,
MORE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
BETTER PROSPECT FOR IMMIGRANTS